今天尾盤狂殺
只殺了307點
為什麼說只殺 因為還不到1%
但是有一些個股
國巨 記憶體殺得非常凶
誇張的走勢
台灣股市是不是要二次破底呢
會不會真的跌破4萬點了
今天三大重點
台灣股市尾盤急殺
9月不妙嗎 怎麼辦
第二個 台積電20座廠全部蓋完了
依然跟不上AI需求嗎
這很恐怖 那這是利多
可是有沒有變現
大家說的AI泡沫
可以蓋晶圓廠啊 可以蓋AI伺服器啊
問題是這些資料中心是真的嗎
第三個 UBER大裁員
是利多還是利空
大家好 我是摩爾投顧分析師
郭哲榮投資長
也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
不只 140萬粉絲的分析師
今天台灣股市滿慘的
可是我告訴大家
行情是等下來的
國巨糜糜卯卯 卯卯糜糜
我要強調一件事
我沒有叫大家買600元的 好不好
有很多人800 1200
這個散戶多了30萬
當然散戶這邊 那一堆散戶
比較不信邪的最後信邪了
最後就是說離開了國巨
會比較好一點
他只能上下的一個波動
可是你看
雖然國巨這樣看起來
好像打二次底
但是我認為低於500元
你說靠近500元的時候
就很多人要買了 好不好
長期的產值還是出來
等一下我要告訴你
這真正的未來趨勢是什麼
這未來趨勢是什麼
我們先唱一首
今天比較不一樣的版本
為什麼說比較不一樣的版本
昨天我們唱這首歌以後
大家反而覺得不錯
可是有人說沒有配樂
有人說不符合時事
因為昨天是欣興嘛
可是今天南電也很慘 是不是
天上的欣興不說話
地上的南電可能要想媽媽 怎麼辦
我們來唱一首歌好不好
唱個之前我一樣要喝個水
導播來一下
很多人不知道導播是誰
我們來唱一下這個歌好不好
昨天有唱過 今天再唱一下好了
音樂沒問題 沒問題
那我們就來準備好了
解答這個行情
天上的欣興不說話
地上的南電想回家
信昌電買完殺呀殺
手中的國巨也趴下
南亞科群聯人人誇
散戶剛買進叫媽媽 媽呀
夜夜想起哲哲的話
閃閃的淚光沒錢花
大家不要緊張
我知道你還有錢
輕鬆一點點好不好
今天應該比昨天更準一點點
所以熟能生巧
買股票也是熟能生巧
我跟大家簡短講一件事 好不好
唱兩次就好
唱第三次就
一鼓作氣 再而衰 三而竭
做事情就是這樣子好不好
為什麼今天要再唱一次
因為股票不一樣了 好不好
博君一笑 等一下好不好
記得一件事 好不好
訊號差
沒錢花了 我知道你還有錢 好不好
可以出道了
今天沒聯電
今天聯電比較好一點點
唱的很好聽 OK
戴什麼口罩 不行
他拿掉口罩有點像渣男 OK
這個跟大家講 來
歌詞寫得真好 卡啦OK台
大家會哭
昨天買國巨 來
摩爾音樂教室上線了
真的是啦 現在當分析師
不過現在當分析師比當藝人好
因為第一個
專業度當然有差啦
以前藝人 我昨天在看節目
以前藝人好像一集
像菲哥這種
一集 1小時可以40幾萬
後來變1小時20幾萬 還要砍價
突然覺得當分析師好像比較好一點點
現在是全民皆AI
你知道台積電
最近員工不是有分紅嗎 是不是
那這個分紅最多乘以8
我不多說他們薪資配的一個程度
基本上現在他們不敢喊薪水太高
大家不相信
我跟你講 我薪水年薪600萬
你們可能覺得在胡扯 沒有
這也代表AI發展是真的
我給你幾個趨勢來告訴你
我們來看一下這個
我們先講這些AI以後
我再跟你講
我直接講AI是真的
我還是要講一件事情
拉回你們趕快買
AI會不會泡沫
越來越不像了
為什麼越來越不像
我先喝個水一下
我先讓導播來一下
不要只有導播唱歌
我們念一下
我們今天一個不錯的訊息
帆宣 因為今天的帆宣
6196帆宣有沒有看到
還能逆勢翻紅 為什麼
因為他說這些支出
好像是說增加150%也不夠
這些設備廠商
所以台積電資本支出的設備廠商
今天都很強
好不好 這是帆宣
我們來念一下帆宣的恭賀簡訊
念完以後告訴你
需求是真的 供給不夠
為什麼需求是真的
我們來念一下 來
好 9月3號禮拜四 今天的簡訊
恭喜6196帆宣
股價表現不錯
大盤震盪依然逆勢收紅
我們多次買進
最高已經大賺46%
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
你們要開心好不好
今天很多股票可以買
比如說華邦電
焦家的集團
2344華邦電
我真的覺得這邊都可以買了
現在很多股票二次探底 為什麼
當然最好的一段已經過了
那不代表之後不行
我們慢慢跟你講
因為今天是半導體廠
我把它說成就是說
它只是一個利多出盡的一個題材
我們來看一下這個新聞 來
這個你們看一下
這個Google直接說了
有沒有看到
Google的首席技術長有沒有直接說
他說需求
AI算力需求沒有上限
你看喔 這是我們做的AI圖
你看我是全台灣最了解AI的分析師
你去比較一下
我們摩爾做的AI圖
這個都比人家厲害
這個AI圖不是我找美編做的
我們直接找研究團隊
所以其實現在很多公司的設計師 美編
其實他們也會面臨到AI的轉換
你懂不懂 甚至很多人被裁員
你自己看
一般人沒辦法做這麼漂亮 這種配色
沒辦法 這都是我們自己做的
那為什麼我做的特別漂亮
因為我懂AI
光是這一點你就知道
我是全台灣最懂AI的
歡迎比較 你有美感的你就知道
我是全台灣做AI圖最漂亮的
你不要覺得這很簡單
會問問題 要會問問題
來 我們來看一下
欣興說產能極度告急有沒有看到
好啦 我知道你都講這是供給面
我供給很多
我知道今天也有那個
ChatGPT 奧特曼也有講
說什麼 說不好意思
這個供給很多
可是問題是也有一些
Neocloud
就是一些賣雲端的人 怎麼樣
先建好資料中心等客人
那這些資料中心如果等客人等不到
會不會影響GPU的定價
我知道你很想說這些泡沫
來 我們來看一下
先來看這些廠商都沒有
因為這些需求可能是假的
我的需求是假的
可是台積電告訴你需求不是假的
沒關係 你可能覺得
有人先訂貨 先訂單
以後可能賣不出去
你們是這樣想
我先跟台積電訂單
我先跟美光要記憶體
我先跟欣興要ABF載板
你看他們全部都說
聯發科說拜託 日月光 鴻海拜託
多一點產能有沒有看到
然後台積電說不好意思
AI需求30年未見
20個廠同時推進仍然供不應求
美光說記憶體未來數年
仍將嚴重供給不足
戴爾昨天最新的財報也說
現在就是等記憶體
欣興也說極度告急
你們股票還在跌
其實我覺得往好處想
這麼大的利多
大家就是缺貨缺得要命
股票還跌
代表什麼意思
這不是所謂利多出盡
代表是大家有警覺
很怕2000年泡沫
越是這樣警覺
你們越不敢追國巨
我跟你講行情會噴出去
可是他要磨啊 磨啊
散戶受不了
磨啊 磨啊
50萬的散戶在買國巨
可能要變45萬 變40萬
他才拉起來
就這樣子 這就是股市而已
所以你偶爾聽聽我唱歌
這個跟大家講好不好
5000多人沒關係
我跟你講一件事 都沒關係
幸好我這次國巨
我不是1000多塊叫你買
是600元以下
4 500元叫你買
拉回就買嘛
我叫你3到5成 最多就5成
被動元件最多5成
你以後會謝謝我好不好
我真的覺得我贏
我不能說百分之百
我是合格分析師
我不是網紅
所以我不會像有些網紅
會偷偷做股票
拉貨給你 出貨給你
我也不要做這種事情
我就禁得起考驗 好不好
我一直跟大家講 來
所以我告訴你
他是真正實實在在的需求
所以我不是那種網紅
我是合格分析師
所以我不會說百分之百
但是我說勝算 我會說滿高的
好啦 台積電說AI產能追不上需求
有沒有看到
再蓋10廠也沒問題
問題是怎麼樣
問題是生態系沒到位
你其他的設備廠有辦法嗎
我已經增加20廠了
再蓋10廠 你懂我意思嗎
設備需求有沒有看到
6個月內已經爆增2倍的情況
沒有人完全跟上
就已經20廠在同時蓋了也不夠
你還要再蓋10廠
大家沒有人能跟上
就算台積電我想蓋
也人力也不足啊 你知道嗎
美國廠很多人都說台積電派人去
能派多少人 現在又少子化
你看 設備的數量調到1.9倍
你還要再調幾倍
不是每個人都可以
你少一個環節就不行
就像記憶體一樣
你AI伺服器
我台積電生出晶片又怎麼樣
我AI伺服器少了晶片也很難出貨
不是 少了記憶體也很難出貨
一樣啊
我台積電要擴產怎麼辦
我設備少一個設備
可能就不行開了
這都一樣 人力需求
所以沒那麼簡單
工班與人力
這都是我告訴你
就是產業
業界告訴你很多人下訂單 好
那你們覺得這個
Google也說需求無上限
台積電也說很多人下訂單
那這個訂單有沒有可能假的
什麼叫假的
Overbooking啊
重複下單啊
或先買晶片再說啊
先建伺服器廠房
先建AI資料中心再說啊
有沒有可能
你們講的都有可能
這是今年台股最大的鬼故事
可是這個鬼故事是假的
我們來看一下
Uber突然大裁員
3300人丟飯碗
完全的遠距離員工只留1%
有沒有看到
那為什麼丟
第一個 管理階層人數減少
他們管理層也太多了吧
其實還有什麼
他是不好意思講 還有什麼
你去想就知道了
你覺得Uber最重要的是什麼
Uber的核心是什麼
請你Tell me
請你可以在底下留言
我直接告訴你
Uber最大核心就是
他的計算能力
我這一筆訂單
你知道為什麼一開始我是用熊貓
結果我後來用Uber
熊貓是這樣子
跟我講20分鐘等了一個多小時
我用了2次以後
我這輩子不用熊貓
難怪熊貓最後被人家吃掉
跟我說20分鐘要一個多小時
第一個人不夠
錢不夠多 你懂嗎 好
錢委屈或心委屈
這兩個 好 那我也說得很清楚
那Uber最大的能力就是
第一個 要能清楚計算
我叫這台車要等多久
就算你叫我等一小時也沒關係
我提早一小時叫
可是Uber是非常準確的
你跟我講1分鐘內會到
或者Ubereats 我叫食物
你跟我講說我等30分鐘到
他真的基本上就30分鐘
正負10分鐘
越來越準的情況之下
那我就會怎麼樣
我就會叫這個Uber
或叫這個食物
我算一算鼎泰豐 我會叫鼎泰豐
鼎泰豐要一小時
我已經知道了
Uber每次都跟我講一小時
那就算我12點半要訂
我11點半一開業的時候
中午一開始的時候我就訂了
提前一小時
所以它最強大是
你要精準計算這些時間 你懂不懂
然後配送這些人員
然後誰要接這個訂單
誰要載這個人
誰要拿這個食物
這是它最重要的核心
那最重要的核心這些都是什麼
工程師相關的
所以你裁這3300人
一定有很多是工程師相關的
那為什麼工程師相關 AI啊
現在已經有人講了
你公司可以設計一個網頁
然後你有一個什麼購物欄
什麼東西 或線上客服
全部按一鍵
Claude有個程式
按一鍵就可以了
10分鐘就可以產出了
這會很多人失業
也會產生很多新產業
也會產生新的需求
你看Uber 3300人
我一個人300萬就好了
年薪 這不高吧
如果是工程師
300萬年薪 我一年省100億
我10年省1000億
我就算砸100億去投資AI又怎麼樣
我是Uber投資AI又怎麼樣
我接下來10年 20年我賺錢
那你現在一間公司投資100億
所以你一定覺得奇怪
奇怪我怎麼要投幾千億美金
差很多 會創造台幣投資AI
我只是其中一家
我還沒講到說銀行客服
台灣光銀行客服就500億的
光台灣的銀行客服就500億的薪資
我已經跟他對話了
他說得很像真人
他還能跟我講我唱歌好不好聽
我這個手機都跟你講過了
還有什麼 還有AI語音
還有AI教學這一塊
我真的跟你們講一件事
如果你現在聽不懂
除非你自己有小孩
除非你的小孩是需要人家陪伴的
如果你小孩只要能克制自己
不要亂查資料
基本上你們都不需要補習了
不需要了 真的不需要補習
你懂我在說什麼嗎
你看那更恐怖的東西
OpenAI驚爆
人類看不懂AI程式碼
人類已經看不懂AI程式碼了 懂不懂
OpenAI說找一個很厲害的
在OpenAI裡面的
ChatGPT裡面的高階工程師
看不懂AI寫的程式碼
可是那個程式碼通耶
那就跟下圍棋一樣 你知道嗎
你懂不懂
下圍棋一樣
以前下圍棋說不能下中間
不好意思 圍棋都這樣下
以前百年棋譜都丟掉了
看不懂啊
有下圍棋的都知道我在講什麼
你懂不懂
這個AI我看不懂他寫的程式碼
可是居然通耶
寫得比我們最優秀的工程師
還寫得好耶
現在已經到這麼恐怖了 你知不知道
這個AI就改變你們
你知不知道
你們到現在我講了三年了
你還聽不懂AI會取代不用AI的人
你們馬上會被取代
現在已經越來越多事實了 告訴你
你看Uber裁員3300人
10%的員工耶
他有信心
他覺得公司還是會正常營運耶
那這些不就變現了嗎
你們知道現在AI最大問題是
沒有人討論AI是泡沫
只有怕AI投資是泡沫
這兩個不是等號
AI是趨勢 就像網路是不是趨勢
到現在還是趨勢
可你2000年出現網路泡沫 為什麼
投資沒有回本
投資沒有馬上回本
可不一樣 AI進展很快
你看現在開始很多人在裁員
開始很多人裁員 好不好
這個跟大家講
這個OpenAI也是一樣
對 那個我插播一下
那個導播我今天有
這個畫面轉到我這個畫面的時候
感覺會有Lag一下下對不對
再轉回來
一點點 還是昨天就會有這樣子
還是今天特別明顯
那個會 每天都會有嗎
為什麼覺得今天特別明顯
沒關係 我們待會討論一下 好不好
不好意思 哲哲比較追求完美
扯遠了 我剛才是跟導播他們講話
等一下我們再一起開會一下
我就是追求完美的男人
你要相信我看到的未來
你們趕快買
這是台灣最大最大
你可以改變你的人生
尤其是你們
如果你們是銀行客服也好
或者是有些工程師
他真的 你如果是一般工程師
你不是那種高階工程師
你們也會被取代
尤其我說寫程式那種
很多人會競爭激烈
那你不如買個聯發科也好
買一些台灣的AI股也好
保障你下半輩子
你看OpenAI驚爆
人類看不懂AI程式
你看 為什麼
工程師的思維
以前是閱讀每一行
邏輯驗證 然後電腦執行對不對
現在沒有
是驗證後執行就好了
為什麼 只要看可不可以跑就好了
因為AI跑得比你快 你知道嗎
以後逐漸解釋低階 最佳化細節
這些AI做就好了
以前是人類要做的事情
重複性測試都不需要
Debug也不需要了
就是以前花年薪幾百萬 上千萬
你知道嗎 以前還有說
臉書還懸賞給你多少錢
只要你能發現我的網站的問題
你可以Debug出來
你可以找出問題來
馬上優先錄取
馬上給你多少幾百萬的錢
你聽得懂嗎 以前有這樣子
現在不需要了
我的AI隨便都比你們一個天才厲害
他只要告訴你目標是什麼
深入硬體架構理解一下
只要知道目標是什麼
重點是要會問問題
哲哲最強的就是會問問題
所以AI對我來說
為什麼你看我們做的AI圖
都比人家漂亮很多
你可以去看業界所有分析
你們只要告訴我
為什麼他說他股市很厲害
他懂AI
為什麼做個圖
或者不會做AI圖
這是事實
你們不要有些天天
我每天漲停 漲停
你們要聽到每天漲停 漲停
到這種爛行情
現在行情這麼爛
天上的欣興不說話
地上的南電叫媽媽
你聽到他每天漲停板
你還去參加他的會員
被騙是剛好而已
我不是要攻擊誰
我講的是一個現象
我們摩爾投顧的分析師
我們是經過
就是每個老師都很認真
你看我們禮拜六錄影你就知道
你看我說一個分析師
來我們公司錄影
2到3年的訓練
才能上的了檯面 都是一樣
我們研究團隊都是一樣 很精實
有些我也教給他們做這些AI圖
為什麼做得特別漂亮
你就告訴我
所以這都是不一樣了
然後說AI新一代水電
他比方說Token就好了
你們聽不懂Token嘛
那你懂幾度電嗎
一度電 兩度電 不懂啊
可是你現在用電量
我就用幾度電來形容你
一度電現在7塊錢 6塊錢
我不知道多少錢
供應用電多少錢 幫我查一下
7塊錢 以前1度3塊錢
隨著成本提高
那一個Token多少錢
那不用擔心嘛 Token多少錢
那我就成本算這樣子嘛
所以不會賠錢嘛
你會說發電廠賠錢嗎 很少啊
所以你們不要擔心
你記得一件事
發電廠會賠錢嗎
很少 你講的是說
台灣的什麼風力發電 太陽能發電
不是啊 我以前是用Token來算啊
你懂不懂
我用Token來算
那你要產出多少是你的事情啊
我電費給你啊
你公司要去產鋼鐵啊
產水泥 隨便你的事情啊
你懂不懂 它有非常多
所以今天我舉水電我覺得很好
電費1度的電
我就是收7塊錢
你要產生700萬 7千萬
那不關我事
黃仁勳這樣講
不要因為恐懼放慢腳步
否則在面臨競賽中被落下的風險
Token經濟有沒有
每百萬Token收入
因為Token是最基本的一個單位
所以應該是用每百萬token
來做一個收入 你懂不懂
一單位智能
但是你不能用一單位智能來算錢
這樣很麻煩
那跑不了多少東西
每百萬Token來收入
你這樣懂不懂
所以這個邏輯很對
我也會用電費 幾度電來看
幾度電你看得出來嗎
你不能看 你也不知道
可是你就說
我就是用這個來當我的
收錢的方式
以後雲端公司 AI資料中心
台積電所有產這些東西
就是為了產的一個Token
一個百萬Token
每100萬Token收多少錢
我就是不要賠錢 那你要怎麼辦
你覺得電力會需求越來越少嗎
不會嘛
你這樣懂我的意思嗎
就像資料中心會需求越來越少嗎
就跟你講一些例子了
我再講一個恐怖的例子 來看一下
助理沒有給我那個圖
我本來要給他
助理馬上生出來給我圖
來這個知名數學家
有人說是全世界最聰明的
數學家陶哲軒
他直接說什麼
這個沒有
這個應該是助理做的 我快氣死了
這個雖然做得很漂亮
但是做得不夠漂亮 做得不夠好
沒關係啦 他們今天其他有做好
這個不是我要的東西
來 助理給我新聞吧
他結論是什麼
結論是陶哲軒認為
他已經贏不了AI了
廢話 我早就跟大家講了
我不是嗆他
他可能 因為有時候人
這沒辦法 我不要這樣講
人家比我聰明
可是我了解AI 你懂不懂
你了解胡瓜 我了解董至成
我董至成 你懂不懂
你了解 你懂製程
你是台積電懂製程
可是不代表你懂股票 你懂不懂
他懂數學不代表懂AI
我是不是有講過一件事
你看陶哲軒
假設陶哲軒不用AI
陶哲軒會被用AI的數學家給幹掉
我舉例子 所以我告訴你們
是越專業的分析師也好
律師也好 分析師我不管他
除非你在摩爾我才教你
這個沒辦法
我也不攻擊別的東西
我們摩爾分析師大家互相求進步
會用AI的分析師
或會用AI的醫生 會用AI的律師
會取代不會用AI的律師 醫生 分析師
就這麼簡單
陶哲軒已經這樣跟你講了
他說他根本就看不懂
天啊 我覺得他做的這個好爛
做的好爛 這個完全沒重點
助理趕快生出來最新的 有點受不了
回答我一下
完全沒重點 這個我就會念他們
我要的重點他完全沒給我
反正陶哲軒直接講一句話
助理可不可趕快 至少給我截圖吧
我趕快叫他們截圖
人家新聞記者都用得比你好
所以我跟你講
所以這個他們有時候
也會犯這樣的問題
會用AI 圖片看起來很好
有些分析師是這樣子
我們摩爾的分析師 還有包含我
我應該是最少數的
就是雖然用AI
我們圖片還算漂亮
有些人是圖片不漂亮
然後答非所問
這就不是我要的AI圖
他們生給我了
沒關係 我大概有時候幾百張才一張
就是我要的重點是什麼
我要的重點是知名數學家陶哲軒
直接自己承認他已經比不上AI了
他說幾年前
你可以解一般的國中數學 高中數學
到現在已經可以解研究所
甚至解幾百年來解不開的數學
他沒辦法 他精力沒辦法十足
就像下圍棋一樣
你根本看不懂他怎麼下
他最後贏了 你懂不懂
他說他數學這樣講
我根本不知道你怎麼解這個程式
怎麼解開來了 他不知道
還有啊 都一樣喔
下圍棋的也是覺得
為什麼電腦會這樣想
怎麼會下這一手
幾百年來沒有 圍棋也幾百年
幾百年來沒有這一手
這個時間怎麼會下這一手
以前下這一手會被老師打 會被老師罵
會被老師抽鞭子
不是
數學家
現在全世界數一數二最強的數學家
說他看不懂AI寫的這些數學
結果還是能解出問題
OpenAI也直接跟你講
他的最高階工程師告訴你
我看不懂他寫的AI程式碼
但是他的AI程式碼怎麼樣
寫的比我還好
寫的比我還快
而且跑起來速度很快
好恐怖喔
不是同一個事情嗎
都看不懂啊
結果做的都比我好 做的比我妙
這些東西我講多久
我足足講3年了
而且這1年我越來越肯定
我是預言家 我告訴你
你們要 天上的欣興不說話
地上的南電叫媽媽
或是國巨一買就趴下
笑哲哲 我不要
那是你的人生
我沒有在乎 我的意思是說
如果你看那麼短 把我看那麼短
我是要當預言家的 我是跟你說真的
那你 哲哲
講那麼多就是沒賺錢
你去找那種做圖很普通的
天天跟你講漲停板 別家投顧的
那不是我要的 你懂嗎
我今天就算我 我跟你講
我工作量已經減一半了
我工作量還是很多老師的2倍 3倍
我還是做很多事情
我的生命就是燃燒在股市
你要懂我看懂的股市
這三個都是一樣啊
你們如果有人在下圍棋啊
或者有人在怎麼樣也好
助理給我圖片有沒有 沒有啊
我們也是引用新聞
沒關係 我引用某一個
蕭上農的沒關係
這個其實很多新聞都有講 好不好
他說陶哲軒都說
這個不只引用這位先生用的
沒關係 其實新聞有講 影片有講
陶哲軒都說
他已經跟不上自己的領域了
有沒有看到 跟不上了
他描述的進度階梯是這樣子
4年前AI 就是2023年
能解國中數學題有沒有看到
接著是高中題
2023年的時候
我說AI股漲一整年
我去知名財經節目
那個財經節目 不好意思
但是我們現在更紅了 我說實在話
跟那個主持人講
AI股會漲一整年
眼睛瞪大的
我不知道是節目效果還是不相信我
我想說我還沒講三年
結果到現在漲3年
現在哪個老師不會講AI股
大家覺得那些AI股好像是那種
只是很普通的
以前什麼列印 叫什麼列印
忘記了
對 3D列印 那種很普通的
是不是 或者是說那個什麼眼鏡
虛擬眼鏡啊 那種東西
那種假議題啊
然後主力要炒的議題啊
不是 我就是要開大門走大路
你看4年前能解國中數學題
再來高中題 再來奧林匹亞等級
研究所資格 有沒有
現在開始解開
沒有什麼人研究的小型未解問題
因為大家都大型研究
大型的未解問題
最近出現一兩次有沒有看到
AI解開人類真的怎麼樣
很努力嘗試過問題
人類集體轉錯彎了 有沒有看到
思考偏向不同的AI
拼湊出相當聰明的解法
有沒有看到 因為之前下錯了
就是人類都像以前下圍棋一樣
不能下中間的地方
不能下這個地方 這個地方
下這個地方穩輸的
沒有 AI說這是最佳解
這個AI怎麼會寫這個程式
我一個程式都看不懂
每一個程式編碼都看懂
加起來我看不懂
跟哲哲一樣有點閱讀障礙
怎麼這樣
結果他寫出來的程式又快又好
這個13歲就拿到
國際數學奧林匹亞金牌
媒體叫他數學界的莫札特
有沒有看到
所以你要越來越懂我講的東西
你們不用AI
你們在各行各業都會被淘汰
真的 你相信我
好不好 你先投資AI
沒有人比我還關心你們的未來
OK嗎 OK
今天怎麼沒講股票 感覺不妙
要講股票了 好不好 來
我剛才講那麼多重要的事情
你還聽不懂
就是AI是完全趨勢
第一個AI可以變現 隨時可以變現
你懂不懂
AI現在已經有一個成熟的計價模式
每百萬的Token
就像一度電一樣
電力廠會賠錢嗎
電力需求越來越多
賠錢就變貴一點
一度電從3塊錢 變4塊錢 變5塊錢
國巨這邊籌碼太亂了
就這樣子而已 好不好
投信在賣沒有關係
股票就來來回回 好不好
來來回回
該買就買 你不要想太多好不好
OK嗎 股票都是這樣子
散戶都看很短
昨天大摩什麼5000 6000
大家冷靜一件事情
哪個分析師在1000多塊的時候
用力買聯發科
我那時候趨勢看得很清楚
我說聯發科都1000多塊
把聯發科換成什麼
把台積電換成聯發科
有印象的請舉手
那時候1000多塊
把台積電換成聯發科
請你舉手喊有沒有 有沒有記得
1000多塊漲到4000多塊
瞬間每個分析師都有聯發科
瞬間每個外資
都要提供聯發科的目標價值
然後到5000 到6000 到1萬
我跟你講
我的投資心態就是人妻我娶
人妻不要娶 人棄我娶
人家丟棄的 我要拿取
人取我與
人家要取的 我送給他
國巨就是這樣子送給他
被動元件送給他 環球晶送給他
台積電到時候擴產了
不會希望這些矽晶圓
記憶體要擴產不會需要這些矽晶圓
這是台灣少數
整個還沒有爆發的缺料題材
到時候全部的電子
基本上都會缺料 都會漲一圈
你懂不懂
他是少數還有爆發力
你要相信我
我是那個3037欣興
被會員罵到臭頭的分析師
那這次1000跌到920
大家快瘋掉
你知道我那時候是
100多元跌到70塊
我最近有在查一個
我要跟你講一個報告進度
就是之前有人亂搞 媒體亂搞
那不算媒體 那是不知名的
我要自救會啊
我不只是不起訴 我是簽結
是要至少兩個檢察官
然後後來我查到法條
因為不好意思 我們律師比較厲害
他說簽結不能
那個書記官可能疏忽了
簽結不能沒有文件給我
所以接下來我有文件
我會印出來給大家看 好不好
印出來給大家看 證明我的清白
全台灣唯一
證交所相關證明我
我絕對沒有跟主力配合
我歡迎你來查
我絕對沒有偷偷賣股票
我不會自己亂買賣
也不可能用人頭戶 該查都查過了
那時候欣興70塊
被人家罵得要死
1000塊的欣興我不屑一顧
我管你ABF載板缺貨
漲了10倍了 我管你缺不缺貨
我找就找那種還沒漲的
我問你國巨到現在
假設到400多塊
他漲1倍 2倍
低基期你是能賠到哪邊去
我就是不要你受傷啊
我要你受傷 我可以買正2啊
我可以買00981A啊
我也說 如果是我
我可能買00981A
我賺更多啊
我都有講啊 人在做天在看
我都歡迎你
我不一定說
我不能說我是超級道德魔人
我每天私底下講話彬彬有禮
我脾氣也有點差
可是投資的道德
我絕對是最高水準
我告訴你 你久了你會愛上我
你會看到我的預測未來
我都預測在對 好不好
我有跟投資長合照過 謝謝
最近越來越多粉絲看到我會尖叫
你知道我走在路上 我壓力很大
來 這個跟大家講
Lily的事情
那個改天再跟大家說明一下
那個沒什麼 對啊 來
不是沒什麼 改天再說
這個你們可以
重點是股票的事情 好不好
不要洗版
其實你有沒有發現到
我現在主持人
我都是慢慢讓他話越來越少
因為我發現重點還是在我身上
這個跟大家講
因為我發現你們雖然說要看美女
我股票不準的時候有美女也沒用
這個跟大家講好不好 來
欣興要賣掉停損嗎
欣興我不會追 我跟你講好不好
改天再講這個東西 來
我也想遇到哲哲本人
來 先跟大家
最近航運也會亂 上海港塞船
來 我們先看一下
這是欣興
大家重點還是回到股票
我送大家一個美女帥哥
然後可是我天天讓你賠錢
你要看我的節目嗎
還是股票 好不好
我們今天股票慢慢來講
因為今天股票真的有些跌得很慘
群聯怎麼看
群聯明明沒漲
會不會打第二隻腳
我從頭到尾我就覺得
拉回你一定要做多
你一定要記得我這句話
拉回你要做多
群聯這種走勢
這邊打第二隻腳 這種走勢
不要說第二隻腳
會不會回到這邊
之前的低點這邊 會不會
這邊低點會不會
前一波這邊低點
會不會這邊的低點
導播看這個手
可不可以再多一點點出去
不行了嗎 差不多了
極限了嗎 導播
這邊低點有沒有
回到這邊的低點
會不會回到這邊低點
我覺得不會 機率很低
第一個 我已經講了
越來越多趨勢證明我講的
Google說AI需求無上限
Google不是
Google你記得一件事
Google比較像客戶端
他也有賣晶片
他自己也有在使用AI
他不是像台積電這樣子
客戶叫我生產我就生產
那有可能是泡沫
有可能Overbooking 重複下單
Google是告訴你這個
就是我自己有在用AI
我們有生產AI
我們生產AI程式
我是真的需求很大
我告訴你這些東西
AI的需求很恐怖
因為太多人還是覺得泡沫
沒有關係 等到10萬點他們都泡沫
我再講一次
悲觀的人邏輯正確
樂觀的人賺走一切
你要樂觀還是悲觀的人
Fine 而且我跟你講
沒有人在第四季做空的
第四季做空的勝算機率實在太低了
空手機率也是很可惜 可憐 可悲
記得這句話
你不講還好
前陣子不是47000了嗎
已經到可憐了
43000馬上可惜了
47000可憐 50000可悲
到時候50000再刺激大家一下
好不好
看一下 念一念以後
助理生出來一個圖
看一下
AI帶來直升機效應
為什麼直升機
AI不是告訴你怎麼走路
它是從終點 直接帶你到
從起點直接帶你到終點
也不跟你講解題的過程
其實還是有告訴你解題的過程
我覺得那是因為陶哲軒
沒辦法 我跟你說沒辦法
我不是批評他
每個人都有每個人的盲點
就是我有時候看這個人
看這個人感情關係
看這個人管理關係
我馬上可以講出這個問題
可是有時候我自己的事情
有時候得要朋友跟我講才能看到盲點
陶哲軒這樣講也不對
其實AI已經告訴你怎麼走了
解程式的過程中就告訴你怎麼走
怎麼會不知道
它是說AI帶來直升機效應
就是我從起點直接帶你到終點
他說你們都不會那種探索的過程
那是不是就少了邏輯推演
我覺得不會
因為他這種說法是
業內人士總會有一點 還是抗拒
人性都是這樣
哪一天AI要贏過我的時候
我也會抗拒
可是重點是什麼
重點是他說私有公司成果
成功率是不是不透明
成功率透不透明不重要
成本高 總比你花了
找了幾十位數學家
然後一輩子可能解不出來的題目
它成本怎麼會高
所以你看 不是我要嗆他
真的不好意思
如果比數學我一定是跟他比
我一定算傻瓜一樣
可是你看比這個時候
我比邏輯就對了
陶哲軒就是個數學天才
那個數學界的莫札特
莫札特有聽過吧 神童
他說這個
如果我沒有誤解他的意思是說
這是私有公司的成果
高成本 成功率不透明
這個邏輯不對
你管它成本高不高
有些人花了一輩子
花了幾百年數學題目都沒有成功
我只要願意花錢
就可以解開了
你們幾百年不能解的數學題目
成功率低又怎麼樣
所以這個不是重點
可是陶哲軒卻說是
你懂我的意思嗎
所以哲哲最強的是
有時候我的邏輯反而很清楚
你看我比數學邏輯我輸他
可是比這件事的邏輯
我覺得他根本不應該擔憂
所以你要了解一個真的懂AI的人
你聽我的邏輯
為什麼很多工程師喜歡看我的節目
為什麼很多醫生喜歡看我的節目
因為我的邏輯是對的
投資朋友我的邏輯是對的
我管你成功率高不高
他說成功率很低
然後難題仍是隨機亂猜
就是一次
100個難題裡面我只能解5個難題
So what 還是解了
是不是 而且那是現在
那以後怎麼辦
100個難題裡面
一輩子解不出來的難題
100個難題可能變50個 變成70個
是不是
那就是用直升機跟探路
人類是直接探路
AI直接載你到瀑布
人類是慢慢找到瀑布
所以這個 沒有辦法
這是非常優秀的人物
非常優秀 非常聰明
但是遇到自己的事情的時候
完全沒想透
當然不好意思
我還是要說他是天才中的天才
我說這件事他的邏輯
我並沒有百分之百認同
我要跟大家講 好不好
我沒有要嗆他
沒辦法 人都會這樣
遇到事情的時候都沒辦法接受被取代
沒辦法
我就盡量把我自己抽離
所以股票也是要抽離
最好的方式就是選低基期股票
投資朋友 其實我是很面對我自己的股票
我不面對自己股票
我根本不會開什麼自己玩笑
南亞科 群聯怎麼樣
人人誇 是不是 你看
可是這個股票你拉起來
該拉回就拉回
只能說半導體展比較多利多
大家覺得利多我反而先走了
沒有關係
台灣現在的主力大戶
之後可能會後悔
中實戶 也不要說後悔
他們只是短進短出
很多中實戶也會看我的節目
看久了他們都會認同
台灣股市我覺得
不到10萬點不回頭
我真的認為
但是你不要說再跌100點
跌300點叫回頭 那我沒辦法
每個人的邏輯
每個人的想法不同
你記得我這些話 好不好
不是每個人的邏輯
每個人的判斷不同
我講的是說
我覺得台灣股市
不會真正一個超級大崩盤 好不好
數學老師不一定會買股票
人家是天才
我剛才不是要說服他買股票
我是要跟他講說
他擔心AI就是成功率很低
那不是重點
至少他能解一些
他就算成功率只有1%
也比那些0%的
然後一輩子解不出來
那群數學家解不出來題目強
有意義 有幫助 你懂不懂
這個跟大家講 來
大家都在問南亞科
你來這邊問有用嗎 問就不要買
我們看南亞科
我不會去買南亞科 你知道嗎
就太高了 你懂不懂
從頭到尾太高了 你知道嗎
太高了
這邊南亞科的大戶
如果沒記錯的話
剛好也是金居的大戶
我就說了
那他就習慣邊創新高
看起來有邊拉邊出的感覺
可是至少不錯
他就讓大家一起賺 你懂不懂
讓大家一起賺 OK嗎
這個股票是這樣子
所以我覺得南亞科拉回很正常
都漲那麼多了
你為什麼要找一個高基期的股票
為什麼不找低基期股票
你自己看
他根本就不像有股災的方式
那我寧願拉回買群聯
我拉回買華邦電 是不是
群聯 華邦電我拉回就買
我覺得OK啊 我是認真的啊
對啊 好不好 這個跟大家講
來 我們看一下
我前年才加入就很欣賞你 謝謝大家
來 我是你忠實粉絲 謝謝
記憶體本益比比傳產股還低
因為大家覺得明年不行了
就像很多人覺得這是景氣循環股
我就說了 越來越多人不懂AI越好
他們覺得景氣循環股
我不懂什麼叫景氣循環股
如果5年 10年都這樣子
也是景氣循環股嗎
這個跟大家講
金居 南亞科的大戶很佛心
他會拉新高
對 這個應該同一位主力
他還是很佛心啊
是啊 還是讓大家拉新高 好不好
0050跟006208
對我們小資族來說有什麼差別
現在0050好像成本比較低了
沒什麼差別 你喜歡買什麼就買什麼
買0050比較好 比較好講話
比較跟我有共通的話題
講006208有些人還不懂
0050就懂 好不好
沒有什麼差別啊
台積電的
其實你這個問題問我
實在是很侮辱我
這是小學生等級的
你直接問網路
不用問到AI
你直接問網路就可以
Google搜尋就告訴你答案了
我直接告訴你沒有差 好不好
有差也差不多 我懶得講
買0050就好了 好不好 OK嗎
哲哲我是人妻 娶我
這個開玩笑
今天怎麼那麼多留言啊
美國要課台灣的關稅
不會 美國對台灣人不錯啊
那只是個威脅而已 好不好
萬潤 6187
萬潤我看一下
萬潤以前不到100塊就被人罵
萬潤不用看
就是資本支出概念股還是會增加嘛
你懂我的意思嗎
請問哲哲會明天開高走低嗎
你們很奇怪
有時候我有感覺開高走低 不代表
我知道明天開高走低
不代表我知道後天
你不要每天問我啊
有時候沒有Fu 你懂我的意思嗎
環球晶怎麼看
認真 大家認真好不好
認真一下 我剛才講了環球晶
你這樣不尊重我
100條什麼 領帶是不是
你們跳好快
我的領帶不只100條吧
現在這個畫面沒有小框框會擋到圖卡
可是比較好看啊
擋到圖卡沒關係
我盡量再移一下 好不好
應該你們比較喜歡這個畫面吧 好不好
應該大家比較喜歡這個畫面吧
不然我們投票一下 好不好
來 這個畫面
原本的畫面還留著嗎
這個畫面 來換一下
這個畫面 不是
這個畫面 有邊框的
來 無邊際的
要有邊際的還是無邊際的
這是有邊際的
這是無邊際的
無邊際當然比較好
有時候還可以指著
而且人比較大啊
有時候會遮住圖片啦
那個一兩個而已啦
重點是我講的內容 好不好
你們要有邊際的還是無邊際的
應該無邊際的比較好吧
這是無邊際的
投票表決一下 好不好
這個畫面比例不錯啊
對啊 比例不錯 我美感很強
請問哲哲大大
轉折是不是要來了 空頭來了
我跟你說真的
我不會說一定不會跌破4萬
可是我會說機率真的有夠低
你們都聽不懂嗎
現在已經很多 越來越多
你要讓一個天才中的天才承認AI贏他
那是很殘酷的一件事
那是很殘忍的一件事
可是越來越多領域發現了
沒有 我是天才工程師
我看不懂AI在寫什麼程式
可是他寫得比我好
寫得比我快
然後程式跑起來比我快
我是數學家 我是天才中的天才
以前沒有人是我的對手
可是我現在比不上
會用AI 然後數學普通的人
你知道那多大的打擊嗎
你們現在還不懂AI改變你的人生
Uber已經在裁員了
你們很快那些做客服的人員
你們以後真的 我真的希望哪一天
走在路上的客服人員說哲哲謝謝你
因為你的關係我改變工作了
因為你的關係我投資股票買AI了
謝謝你 你叫我什麼都不懂
買台灣50就好
這個東西比我賺到1億我還開心
我是認真的
比我去捐救護車一樣開心
我真的希望能改變大家的人生
你聽得懂嗎 好不好
台積電員工 我跟你講
很多人說台積電員工現在很自負
可是你們要了解
是時代選擇你們
我不是在噹你們
十幾年前的人
台積電會知道這個事情嗎 不知道
所以我們要珍惜這個年代 你懂不懂
趁這個時候賺錢
我覺得台積電員工都很優秀
可是不代表以前的
以前去台積電的人
離開台積電的人就不優秀
沒有 剛好這時代選擇了各位
所以你要把握這時代
股票要賺 工作的錢也要賺好不好
無邊際看到哲哲寬厚的雙肩 謝謝
比例還OK 來
小缺點 還好不介意
無邊際比較多對不對
看一下
有沒有 無邊際比較多
這是無邊際 85% 有邊框 差很多
哲哲 國巨可以買
我叫你All in就All in
不是叫你All in單一檔股票
每次都有人斷章取義我的話 好不好
我想了解一個問題
AI取代許多人的基本飯碗
但大多數人不是天才
大多數人真的不是天才
但是他要生活 他沒有基本薪水
他如何消費
我覺得你這個邏輯不對
會取代很多人的飯碗
但是你只要努力
你還是可以 還是有工作
會創造新的需求 你相信我
就像以前有想過Uber的人那麼多嗎
現在路邊都是Uber
你十年前有想過嗎
那還不是有新的需求出來
有新的行業跟新的需求
蒸汽時代對不對
工業革命發明了
以前裁縫都用人力
不是用裁縫機
大家覺得工作是不是越來越少
怎麼辦 都需要蒸汽機來取代我
沒有嘛
你們都說了大多數人不是天才
那沒有關係
但是他說大多數人不是天才
沒有關係 我覺得只要知足
認清楚自己
最怕的是不認清楚自己的身份
我講的不是攻擊別人 你知道嗎
就是有時候很多人就幻想
這個世界和平
我只要輕鬆工作就好
我也要高薪 這很難嘛
你老闆都會算
可是有一個東西真的是讓你輕鬆
又可以賺錢
買ETF
買ETF 認知的差別就好
定存改去買ETF
真的都跟大家講這些東西好不好
這是最好的時代
也是最壞的時代對不對
陣痛期要怎麼辦 我不是政治家
這個我能幫一個就一個
買ETF啊
買ETF啊 所以我不是跟你講嗎
我專業就告訴你
買ETF或買股票啊 是不是
你風險趨避者 你就買ETF啊
買ETF不要亂買 你不要買主動型
你就買0050 00662
買美國的ETF就可以了 好不好
怎麼會有那麼蠢的問題
金字塔頂端的人能夠存活就好
誰管你社會底層 等著被淘汰
這個是比較嗆 也是實話
當然我覺得
我比較屬於世界大同那種人
我覺得大家有這個問題沒關係
可是這社會上
其實記得一件事
其實我覺得現在社會還是很公平
只要你努力
基本上你不可能沒有工作 OK嗎
你光是現在超商店員
就可以4萬多塊薪水了
哪有可能會失業
你要不要做而已
台灣又少子化了 你要不要做而已
也有人說再過幾十年
台灣從2200萬
40年 50年過後
台灣從2200萬變成1200萬
那足足少了1000萬人
你覺得工作會少1000萬個嗎
是不是 這個東西不重要
你要講 我可以講一整天
我們想多了叫做
天下本無事 庸人自擾之
本來無一物 何處惹塵埃
這句話送給你 不要去想這些東西
你要想的是你此時此刻
你有什麼武器 我們來賺大錢
那賺大錢 你就不要去想工作
工作當然是很重要
工作是調劑你的人生
而工作不只調劑你的人生
也是讓你賺錢
那股票就是讓你賺錢的工具
投資的工具
現在行情好好要把握住
現在幾分鐘
50 今天講好多人生的道理
我覺得不太像分析師
還是要講一下 精材也是一樣
台積電資本支出概念股的股票
都有機會噴出去
3035智原有機會 好不好
3035智原我寧願去追高
站上200元以上再說好不好
因為他AI還是偏遠的
等到他營收出來的時候
他營收出來會比較慢一點
他可能會比環球晶慢
會比國巨慢 好不好
國巨真的沒什麼漲
他要洗也不關我的事
反正籌碼要洗也不關我的事
反正是洗不掉我的
我很能抱 我成本也低
好不好 這個跟大家講
帆宣要噴出去了
聯發科我有考慮再買
助理提醒我一下 我可能買聯發科
我是認真的
今天聯發科還拉起來
聯發科我可能要買
助理提醒我一下
可是我的聯發科 我可能是
比較高等級會員買
我先跟大家講
因為有些低等級會員買不起聯發科
不要說低等級
對不起 我收回我的話
門檻級的 對不起 這樣很得罪人
會員我都愛你們
有些人成本不一樣
有些人只能買30萬成本 40萬成本
這就是我一直呼籲的
我拜託希望台灣股票零股化
用一股為單位 不是用一張為單位
還是持續呼籲一下
我是希望大家每個人都賺到錢
券商也賺到錢 主管機關也開心
你們也開心 好不好
這個行情真的你相信我
今天那麼多人告訴你
AI取代他們了
工程師看不懂
你還懂這個需求是真的嗎
Uber馬上裁員 馬上現賺100億
你還看不懂嗎
這些東西我早就講好久
我講了好幾年了
現在這幾年越來越快浮現
一家 兩家 三家怎麼辦
所以很多的裁員潮
很多的變現 很多公司開始賺錢了
開始AI新創公司了
你要趕快把握住這波大行情
今天股票回檔我反而很開心
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論國巨 不論華新科
被動元件這些回檔
或者記憶體回檔
他都是趨勢
未來的趨勢我一手掌握
我來幫你一起賺大錢
預祝各位能夠真正賺大錢
Byebye